I've talked to a lot of great leaders
there's just not many people like Elon
that would push for Starship
when they're already
had a very successful company yeah uh
sort of everyone doubted that it could
be a successful company it was so close
to bankruptcy and failing and then to
take it into a financially viable
successful company and just when you do
you take on a project that again risks
everything
when he already did this with Falcon 1
to Falcon 9. like literally people were
like what are you doing they basically
signed over and were fully ramping up
Falcon 9 by the time they finally had
their first Falcon one success they had
one more flight they only flew [__]
one successfully twice they flew five
times all together the fourth one was
successful and they flew one more time
and the anyone else out there would have
been like let's keep flying the Falcon
one we have a working rocket we can
start you know making money and
profiting and already he was risking it
all and saying nope we're going from
Falcon one to Falcon 9 was a huge huge
leap you know it was that I think it's
at least as big as a leap from [__]
one to nine as it is from Falcon 9 to
Starship or around relatively a similar
leap so it's just that same thing again
people are going why are you leaping
into this insane program and system and
risk when you have such a you know you
finally have this Workhorse of a rocket
that's so dominant in the industry
yet they're going
10x you know